تمسك بالنظام الدولي المتعدد الاطراف
والقائمه على القانون الدولي يمثل مدخلا
بالنسبه الى الاتحاد الاوروبي لحجز الدعم
الدولي ضد روسيا
نؤمن بميثاق الامم المتحده والقانون
الدولي وسنتحدث عن بعض التحديات التي
نواجهها منها حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
ونثمن دوركم الرياديه خاصه في تامين اتفاق
الحبوب حرب اوكرانيا كانت جزءا من نقاشات
القمم على الامين العام للامم المتحده حول
ازمات الغذاء والتغير المناخي واتفاق
الحبوب مع روسيا واوكرانيا
غزو روسيا لاوكرانيا يتسبب في معاناه
شديده للشعب الاوكراني وله تاثيرات كبيره
على الصعيد العالمي
القمه الاوروبيه صادقت على قرار تمويل
مشتريات اوكرانيا من الذخيره بقيمه مليار
يورو والتمويل المشتريات مشتركه بين دول
الاتحاد لاعاده التشكيل مخزونها من
الذخيره بقيمه مليار اخرى القمه اوصف
بتحفيز صناعه الاسلحه الاوروبيه
هناك حاجه للاسراع في رفع مستوى قدرات
الانتاج الاوروبيه من والاسلحه لذلك نبحث
سبل تحفيز الصناعات العسكريه الاوروبيه
عده دول اوروبيه تسعى الى تشكيل محكمه
خاصه لمقاضاه جريمه العدواني وفق تسميتها
في القانون الدولي محكمه تختلف في
صلاحياتها عن محكمه الجنايات الدوليه في
بيان دعمها اوكرانيا اكدت القمه الاوروبيه
التزامها بدعم انشاء اليه خاصه
لمقاضاه جريمه العدوان حسب ما ورد في
البيان الرسمي الاوروبي
نور الدين الفريد العربيه